>> Bret: PETER DOOCY LIVE ON THE
NORTH LAWN, THANKS.
MORE ON THIS WITH THE PANEL.
IT IS CALLED FOR THE PEOPLE ACT
BUT REPUBLICANS ARE WARNING IT'S
ACTUALLY A POWER GRAB BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
THE G.O.P. SAYS THIS PEOPLE SR-1
WOULD GREATLY EXPAND THE
GOVERNMENT'S ROLE IN ELECTIONS.
DEMOCRATS SAY IT WILL HELP
PROTECT THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOR
ALL AMERICANS.
THE LEGISLATIVE BATTLE AHEAD
BROUGHT THE SENATE MINORITY
LEADER OUT TODAY TO TRADE VERBAL
BLOWS WITH THE MAJORITY LEADER.
CORRESPONDENT JACQUI HEINRICH IS
FOLLOWING THE ACTION FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
>> RARELY IS A BILL MARKUP IN
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE THE
SETTING FOR FIREWORKS OR EVEN AN
APPEARANCE FROM A PARTY LEADER.
>> I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
TODAY.
>> STOP CALLING OUR DEMOCRACY
BROKEN.
>> BUT TODAY BOTH AS DEMOCRATS
ADVANCED A SWEEPING ELECTION
REFORM BILL AND REPUBLICANS DREW
BATTLE LINES.
>> THE EYES OF HISTORY ON R. ON
ALL OF YOU.
>> THE TRUTH IS QUITE SIMPLE.
OUR DEMOCRACY IS NOT IN CRISIS.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE S-1 FOR
THE PEOPLE ACT THEIR TOP
PRIORITY AMID A SLEW OF NEW
STATE ELECTION LAWS THEY SAY
RESTRICT VOTING ACCESS
ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
FRAMING IT AS 21st CENTURY JIM
CROW.
MAJORITY LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER
TIED G.O.P. OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL TO FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> DON'T TELL US THESE LAWS ARE
ABOUT VOTER FRAUD.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT DONALD TRUMP
PERPETRATED THE BIG LIE.
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY, IT SEEMS THE
PRICE OF ADMISSION IN TODAY'S
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS SILENCE IN
THE FACE OF PROVEABLE LIES.
>> MINORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL SHOT BACK CALLING IT
A POLITICALLY MOTIVATED FEDERAL
TAKEOVER OF THE ELECTION SYSTEM.
>> FOR MULTIPLE YEARS NOW
DEMOCRATS HAVE CALLED THIS
SWEEPING BILL THEIR TOP PRIORITY
THIS.  HAS GONE FROM AN ELECTION
SECURITY BILL TO AN ETHICS BILL,
TO A RACIAL JUSTICE BILL.
WHO KNOWS WHAT IT WILL BE
LABELED TOMORROW.
>> THE BILL WOULD DRAMATICALLY
EXPAND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
ROLE IN ELECTIONS.
CREATING AUTOMATIC NATIONWIDE
VOTER REGISTRATION AND EXPANDING
EARLY VOTING AMONG OTHER THINGS.
REPUBLICANS SAY IT DIMINISHES
STATES' RIGHTS.
GUTS POPULAR SAFEGUARDS AGAINST
FRAUD LIKE VOTER I.D. AND TILTS
THE POWER OF THE FEDERAL
ELECTIONS COMMISSION.
BUT DEMOCRATS ARE URGENTLY
PUSHING FORWARD WHILE THEY
MAINTAIN THEIR NARROW MAJORITY.
>> THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF
A MARATHON MARKUP EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE TOMORROW.
REPUBLICANS HAVE 150 AMENDMENTS
FILED.
BUT, BEYOND THAT ITS FUTURE IS A
LOT LESS CLEAR.
DEMOCRATS CAN'T PASS THIS UNLESS
THEY REFORM OR ABOLISH THE
FILIBUSTER, ALLOWING THEM TO
PASS THIS ALONG A PARTY LINE
VOTE.
BUT MODERATE DEMOCRATS, SENATORS
JOE MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN SINEMA
HAVE SAID THEY ARE AGAINST
CHANGES TO THE FILIBUSTER AND
ALSO WANT ANY ELECTION REFORM TO
BE BIPARTISA